what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm Greg Alva fine don't play I'm John
and we're gonna watch the final episode
of stranger things we'll fix up the
lighting for the reaction part I'm
excited we're gonna wrap this up it's
been a great season so far thank you
very one who's been watching since the
very beginning of this season with us
you have it go back another of you can
never hurt this is a last time I'm gonna
say it for stranger things subscribe to
the real rejects and just click that
notification bell thank you to Eric over
at nerd cronic for editing all these
reaction highlights for us please give
him a follow he was done work for people
like Eamon snow acha saw a movie trivia
Schmo down is on podcaster ever
podcaster founder on YouTube as well if
you see on YouTube you can only do 10
minutes worth of reaction highlights so
our stream along full length are over at
our patreon page over there we do stream
logs for many shows haunting of Hill
House Cobra Kai season to Gotham and we
do stream along for several other shows
that have reaction highlights included
those goodies are attack on Titan my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man and
supernatural go ahead and check out our
patreon page let's watch the final
episode we've got to mention we're
dividing this up into two parts this is
the final episode it's really long keep
a look out for part 2 which should be up
soon or you know if you're watching this
one late it's already up so click that
link you know after you're done watching
it's your kids yes we do
[Music]
Jonathas gonna do something
oh just another day knocking go
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yes that's what I was saying just worked
it out
[Music]
Oh
yeah
[Music]
family reunions it all comes to an end
people I like that so I don't worry
about you I've done so it's gonna die
this season
[Music]
[Music]
what is true is
all three of them all three of them
[Music]
there's the orator
- Jonathan's doing more than he's ever
done entire season this is gonna be his
EPS what are Short's meter
oh it's Billy yeah everybody out of the
car whoa
[Music]
over here
Oh God if you need us a nurse they
actually puppy Jenna
Wow how's that there's an alert a whole
bunch of hooker Russian soldiers
[Music]
she's she better show for the last 30
[Music]
scoop truth is said it was right shoe
Billy nice time thinking about your
brother 11 powerless
[Music]
[Music]
but bruschetta salsa as a juice also
catania through the through get a nice
even thickness the lipstick
[Music]
who we are and we love Russian
[Music]
[Music]
like somehow stripper powers
[Music]
[Music]
new things good great transition this is
the way this is supposed to work are you
supposed to say yes I told you so it's
what we needed to go back to the kids we
actually do make it out of here we
deserve to celebrate
Enzo's me
[Music]
[Music]
this is the upside down version of the
previous conversation I mean just when
you say date I really hope one of them
doesn't die please don't I'm worried I'm
worried Joyce is gonna die
you kids die enjoys the offer
[Music]
[Music]
I'm so worried one of them I'm like so
worried
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
it's for the slingshot
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's good God uh Steve showed up
a scary it's definitely bigger than the
upside-down sequences
Oh Susie I'm so excited
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
thousands
Susy no don't try bags
[Music]
ow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kill a popper
[Music]
[Music]
let's go to
[Music]
why
[Music]
part one complete
you